Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club of Rome, the 49th before the birth of Christ. The sun had long set behind the Apennine mountains. Lined up in full marching order, soldiers from the 13th Legion stood massed in the dark. Bitter the night may have been, but they were well used to extremes. For eight years they had been following the governor of Gaul on campaign after bloody campaign, through snow, through summer heat,
谢谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先看，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com，加入公元前49年、基督诞生前的罗马俱乐部。亚平宁山脉背后的夕阳早已落下。第13军团的士兵们全副武装，整齐列队，黑压压地聚在黑暗中。夜色或许寒冷刺骨，但他们早已习惯了极端恶劣的环境。八年来，他们跟随高卢总督经历了一场又一场血腥的战役，踏过冰雪，顶着夏日的酷热，
to the margins of the world. And now, returned from the barbarous wilds of the north, they found themselves poised on a very different frontier. Ahead of them flowed a narrow stream. And Tom Holland, if that very purple prose hasn't sent you to sleep, what was the name of that stream, pray tell? Dominic, the name of that narrow stream was the Rubicon. And who wrote those extraordinary lines, Tom? Dominic, t name of that narrow stream was the Rubicon. And who wrote those extraordinary lines, Tom? Dominic, it was I. It was.
直至世界的边缘。如今，从北方野蛮的荒野归来，他们发现自己正伫立在一个截然不同的边境前。在他们前方流淌着一条狭窄的小溪。托马斯·霍兰（Tom Holland），如果那段华丽的辞藻还没让你睡着的话，请告诉我，那条小溪叫什么名字？多米尼克，那条狭窄的小溪名叫鲁比肯河。是谁写下了那些非同寻常的句子，托马斯？多米尼克，那条狭窄的小溪名叫鲁比肯河。是谁写下了那些非同寻常的句子，托马斯？多米尼克，正是在下。没错。
So that's the beginning of Tom's book, Rubicon. So that's the book that launched you as a historian, isn't it? Yes, it's the first work of history that I wrote. So in a way, my career as a historian. Oh, is everything to those lines. Begins with those lines. With those lines. Extraordinarily, you're still working in history. And here we are.
所以那是托马斯你的书《鲁比肯》（Rubicon）的开篇。所以这也是那本让你作为历史学家一战成名的书，不是吗？是的，这是我写的第一部历史著作。所以在某种程度上，我作为历史学家的职业生涯……哦，这一切都归功于那些句子。都是从这些句子开始的。从这些句子开始。非同寻常的是，你至今仍在从事历史研究。我们现在就坐在这里。
Astonishing. Here we are going back to it. And so we did the 12 days of Christmas over the festive season. And we were talking about anniversaries. And this is another anniversary, isn't it? Because January the 10th. Did it really happen on January the 10th, Tom? Well, as with everything in ancient history, it's complex. I mean, this is the traditional date.
真是令人惊叹。我们现在又回到了原点。在节日期间，我们做了“圣诞节的12天”系列节目。我们一直在谈论周年纪念。这也是另一个周年纪念，对吧？因为1月10日。托马斯，它真的发生在1月10日吗？好吧，正如古代历史中的一切一样，情况很复杂。我的意思是，这是传统日期。
It may have been a couple of days later. And it's further complicated by the incredible difficulty of mapping the Republican era dates onto our contemporary calendar. So by some reckonings, it may have been in late November, which really, but let's just scrub that. So the 10th of January, Julius Caesar crosses the Rubicon. And it is, I think, one of the great moments in world history. It's a moment of incredible drama.
它可能晚了几天。由于将共和时代的日期换算成我们当代的日历极其困难，情况就更复杂了。因此，根据某些推算，它可能发生在11月下旬，这确实……但我们姑且忽略这一点。所以，在1月10日，尤利乌斯·凯撒跨越了鲁比肯河。我认为，这是世界历史上的伟大时刻之一。这是一个极具戏剧性的时刻。
And the measure of that is that really, I think ever since 17th century, maybe even 16th century, in English, the phrase to cross the Rubicon has meant to take an irreversible decision. And the reason that it has that resonance is that Caesar standing on the Rubicon is facing what the Romans called a discremen. It's a moment of excruciating tension that is also a kind of dividing line in his career, because what he essentially has to decide is, does he stand down his command? He's been governor of Gaul for almost 10 years. Does he have to lay down his command,
衡量这一点标准在于，事实上我认为，自17世纪甚至16世纪以来，在英语中，“越过鲁比肯河”（to cross the Rubicon）这个短语就意味着做出一个不可逆转的决定。它之所以能产生这种共鸣，是因为站在鲁比肯河畔的凯撒面对着罗马人所称的“dilemma”（艰难抉择）。这是一个极其紧张的时刻，也是他职业生涯中的一道分水岭，因为他本质上必须决定的是：他是否要解除自己的军权？他担任高卢总督将近10年了。他必须卸下军权吗，
go back to Rome and risk prosecution, potentially the ruin of his career? Or does he stay at the head of his legions and cross the Rubicon, which is the river marks the boundary between his provinces of Gaul and Italy itself. And for him to cross that river, let alone at the head of his legions, is essentially to declare civil war. So the decision could not be more massive. So before we get into the decision, set the scene for us very, very broadly.
回罗马去冒着被起诉、甚至职业生涯毁于一旦的风险？还是继续担任军团统帅并跨越鲁比肯河？这条河是他的高卢省份与意大利本土之间的分界线。对他来说，跨越这条河，更不用说率领着他的军团跨越，本质上就是宣布内战。所以这个决定再重大不过了。因此，在我们深入探讨这个决定之前，请为我们大致铺垫一下当时的背景。
We're in the Roman Republic in the first century BC. So Rome is not yet an empire in name, but it kind of is an empire in fact, isn't it? I mean, it's acquired all this territory in sort of Asia and North Africa and so on. And the republican system, so the picture you paint in your book, which has so many kind of contemporary resonances, doesn't it, with the kind of the American Republic and so on, that the picture you paint in your book is of this extraordinary city, kind of smoky, brick, disputatious, crowded, slum infested city that has risen through military might to become the master of the Mediterranean. And it's sending out generals to the provinces and to the frontiers, commanding these armies who are increasingly unwilling to basically obey the conventions of the political. Is that a fair summary?
我们正处于公元前1世纪的罗马共和国。所以，罗马在名义上还不是一个帝国，但实际上它已经是一个帝国了，对吧？我的意思是，它在亚洲、北非等地获得了所有这些领土。共和体制——正如你在书中勾勒的那样，它与美国共和国等有着如此多的当代共鸣——你在书中描绘的画面是这样一个非同寻常的城市：烟雾缭绕、砖石垒砌、好辩争吵、拥挤不堪、贫民窟密布，它通过军事力量崛起，成为了地中海的主宰。它向各省和边境派遣将军，统帅着这些军队，而这些军队越来越不愿意遵守政治常规。这是一个公平的总结吗？
Essentially, yes. Essentially. I mean, the essence of the Republican system in Rome, it's founded, again, a bit like the American Republic. It's founded with the expulsion of the monarchy. And so the ideal in the Roman Republic, and Republic comes from res publica, it's the public affair. So the idea that every, well, it's male citizen has a stake in the affairs of the running of the city. And the ideal essentially is that the Republic should give free reign to the talents of its people and above all, their yearning for individual honour.
基本上是的。基本上是。我的意思是，罗马共和体制的精髓在于，它和美国共和国有点像，是通过驱逐君主制而建立的。因此，在罗马共和国的理想中——“共和国”（Republic）这个词源于“res publica”，即公共事务。也就是说，每个公民，好吧，是男性公民，都在城市的运营事务中拥有利益。而理想本质上是，共和国应该为其人民的杰出才能提供广阔舞台，最重要的是，满足他们对个人荣誉的渴望。
But those yearnings for individual honour should be subordinated to the honour of the city itself and the Roman people as a collective. And so therefore, there's a kind of ferocious series of constitutional checks and balances that are designed to stop essentially a citizen from becoming overmighty, from making himself the equivalent of a king. And so those would include the division of the king's powers, for instance, between elected officials called consuls who are, you know, there are two of them so that one can always keep an eye on the other. They only serve for two years. This is true of most of the lesser magistracies in the Republic as well. But it's also, it's something that every individual citizen is raised up with a consciousness that kind of king is a dirty word.
但对个人荣誉的渴望应当服从于城市本身的荣誉以及罗马人民的集体利益。因此，有一系列极其严厉的宪政制衡机制，旨在阻止公民变得权势熏天，阻止他把自己变成相当于国王的存在。因此，这些机制包括将国王的权力分给被称为执政官（consuls）的民选官员，他们，你知道的，有两个人，这样一个人就可以时刻监督另一个人。他们只任职两年。共和国里的大多数低阶官职也是如此。但这也是每个普通公民从小就被灌输的一种意识：国王是一个带有贬义的词。
The word Rex is a dirty word that properly your personal Rome and the Romans to emerge essentially from being kind of bunch of cattle rustlers camped out on hills above marshes to as you said ruling the whole of the Mediterranean the problem is with this that the more powerful that Rome becomes so the more opportunities there are for its individual citizens themselves to become powerful. And you end up in a situation where certain citizens at the absolute top of the tree of achievement are able to put the whole republic in their shadow. So this brings us to a question that we had from lots of listeners. Roy Neely, for example, example and he says what's basically
“Rex”（拉丁语中的国王）是一个肮脏的词，你的个人……罗马人和罗马人从最初驻扎在沼泽上方山丘上的一群牛贼，成长为如你所说统治了整个地中海。这里的问题在于，罗马变得越强大，其普通公民自己变得强大的机会也就越多。最终你会陷入这样一种境地：处于成就金字塔最顶端的一些公民能够将整个共和国置于他们的阴影之下。这就引出了许多听众提出的一个问题。例如罗伊·尼利（Roy Neely）说，基本上
what's so special about the rubicon so we're 49 bc caesar takes his troops across the rubicon why is that because he's not the first over mighty individual is he because you've had a civil war between two massive titanic roman figures a generation earlier, Gaius Marius and Lucius Cornelius Sulla. And Sulla had also marched on Rome, hadn't he? So why is that different from Caesar? I mean, it's a good question. Essentially, Roman history in the first century BC is kind of structured around the personal rivalry of kind of charismatic popularists and people who tend to identify themselves with the traditions. So it's this podcast.
鲁比肯河到底有什么特别之处？所以我们在公元前49年，凯撒带着他的军队跨过了鲁比肯河，为什么会这样？因为他并不是第一个权力过大的个人，对吧？因为早在上一代人，两个庞大如泰坦般的罗马人物盖乌斯·马略（Gaius Marius）和卢基乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·苏拉（Lucius Cornelius Sulla）之间就爆发过内战。苏拉也曾进军罗马，不是吗？那这和凯撒有什么不同？我的意思是，这是个好问题。本质上，公元前1世纪的罗马历史大致围绕着富有个人魅力的平民派领袖与倾向于认同传统的人之间的个人敌对展开。所以这是这个播客的写照。
It's the balance of this podcast. Yes, it is a few like you are the charismatic populist and I'm the chilly, stiff, cold traditionalist. I wasn't going to say that.ist I wasn't going to say that I absolutely wasn't going to say that I'm sure I definitely thought of it the other way around so so the the last of these obviously is is um Mark Antony against uh Octavian who becomes Augustus then you've got Julius Caesar who's absolute classic populist against Pompey who's also a populist but ends up uh fighting for fighting for the kind of senatorial elite.
这是这个播客的平衡。是的，如果你愿意的话，你就像那个富有个人魅力的平民派，而我则是那个冷酷、死板、冰冷的传统派。我本来没想这么说。我绝对没想这么说。我确信我从一开始就是反着想的。所以，最后这些人物显然是……马克·安东尼对阵屋大维（即后来的奥古斯都），然后你有尤利乌斯·凯撒——绝对经典的平民派，对阵庞培——他也是个平民派，但最终为了维护参议员精英阶层而战。
And then right at the beginning, you have the, as you say, these two figures, Marius and Sulla. And Marius is a populist. He's a great general. He's not aristocratic. The key thing that he does is that he faces up to the fact that the kind of the traditional days where... So a legion, what does a legion mean? A legion basically is a levy. And the idea is, is that a legio, a levy is simply the Roman people in arms. And so everyone has heard of centurions, centurions command centuries, but centuries are also the voting blocks within the Republic. So there's this idea that the army camp is simply a mirror of the forum, the campus marshes, the plane of Mars, you march out there and you get enrolled in the army and then you go off and fight. Then you come back and you resume civilian life.
而在最开始，正如你所说，你有马略和苏拉这两个人物。马略是一个平民派。他是一位伟大的将军。他并非出身贵族。他做的最关键的一件事是，他直面了这样一个事实：传统的日子……那么，一个军团意味着什么？一个军团基本上就是一次征兵。其理念是，“legio”（军团）、一次征兵，实际上就是武装起来的罗马人民。因此，每个人都听说过百夫长，百夫长指挥百人队，但百人队也是共和国内部的投票区块。因此，人们认为军营只是论坛、战神广场（Campus Martius，战神平原）的镜子，你开赴那里参军，然后去战斗。然后你回来，恢复平民生活。
And this for centuries has been the way that it should organise. The problem is, again, that Rome has become too powerful, that now if you're being enrolled in a legion, you're being sent to serve in Spain or in Syria or whatever. And so it's impractical to imagine that you can just come back. And so rather than having a single legio, a single levy, you start to get multiple levies, multiple legions. And Marius basically professionalizes it. And he says that it's unfair to expect peasants or whatever to go off and not be paid for this service. And so he, essentially, this kind of idea of a citizen militia, which is what the legio had been, becomes what we now think of as the Roman legions and these become professional entities and this makes
几个世纪以来，这一直是组织运作的方式。问题依然是，罗马变得太强大了，以至于现在如果你被编入一个军团，你就会被派去西班牙、叙利亚或其他地方服役。因此，指望你能直接回来是不切实际的。所以，与其只有一个“legio”（单一征兵）、单一军团，你开始拥有多重征兵、多重军团。马略基本上将其职业化了。他说，指望农民或其他人在服役期间没有薪水是不公平的。因此，他把公民民兵的概念（这曾是“legio”的本质）变成了我们现在所认为的罗马军团，它们成为了职业化的实体，这使得
Marius very popular and he becomes consul a record number of times but this generates opposition and envy and the most charismatic figure who is envious of him is this guy called Sulla who is a kind of louche hadn't hadn had a great, you know, hadn't had a meteoric rise, kind of hung out with drag queens and pimps and, you know, in the red light district and all that kind of stuff, but turns out to be a brilliantly successful general and in due course, an absolutely ruthless political operator. And what happens is that there's a kind of war in the East that promises all kinds of loot. It's going to be easy pickings. And Sulla gets the command for that. There are complicated
马略非常受欢迎，他创纪录地多次当选执政官。但这引发了反对和嫉妒，而对最他充满嫉妒的最有魅力的人物是一个叫苏拉的家伙。他有点放荡不羁，没有过……没有过那种火箭般的崛起，经常和人妖、皮条客混迹于红灯区之类的地方，但结果却是一位极其成功的将军，假以时日，更是一个绝对冷酷无情的政治操盘手。当时东方发生了一场战争，预示着各种战利品，这将是一场轻松的掠夺。苏拉得到了这场战争的指挥权。罗马复杂的
political shenanigans in Rome that means he gets stripped of that command. Sulla has the legions ready to go. And rather than accept this, he marches on Rome and Marius is forced to flee so if Sulla marches on Rome isn't that a crossing the Rubicon type moment kind of yes it is why don't we remember why doesn't anybody care about that or do they did they care at the time they did care massively it was an absolutely seismic event right a completely seismic event. And it was absolutely felt to be that. Sulla then goes off to the East. He wins his war. Meanwhile, in Rome, there's been not just a civil war, but a war of the Italians in rebellion against the Romans. Sulla comes back. He
政治权谋意味着他被剥夺了指挥权。苏拉的军团已经整装待发。他不接受这个结果，而是率军进军罗马，马略被迫逃亡。如果苏拉进军罗马，那难道不是一个类似“跨越鲁比肯河”的时刻吗？某种程度上，是的。为什么我们不记得？为什么没有人关心这个？或者他们当时关心吗？他们当时极其关心，这是一场绝对震撼性的事件，对吧？一场彻底震撼性的事件。
embroils himself in that. He crushes the Italians. He crushes his opponents in the Civil War. He establishes himself as the absolute master of Rome. And he dusts down this antique office, which is a very, very ancient one in the Republic. When the Republic is in absolutely desperate straits, you can appoint a single man for a six month term. And the name of this office is dictator. So Sulla is appointed dictator for more than six months because he has the army at his back. He is absolutely ruthless towards his opponents. He has a whole bunch of them massacred in the heart of Rome.
人们确实有这种感受。苏拉随后前往东方。他赢得了战争。与此同时，在罗马，不仅爆发了内战，还爆发了意大利人反抗罗马人的叛乱。苏拉回来了。他卷入了其中。他粉碎了意大利人。他粉碎了内战中的对手。他确立了自己作为罗马绝对主宰的地位。他翻出了这个古老的官职，这是共和国一个非常非常古老的职位。当共和国处于绝对绝望的困境时，你可以任命一个人担任为期六个月的独裁官。这个职位的名称就是独裁官（dictator）。因此苏拉被任命为独裁官，任期超过六个月，因为他有军队做后盾。他对反对者绝对冷酷无情。他在罗马市中心屠杀了一大批反对者。
He then puts the price on people's heads. He posts prescription lists in the forum. People are paid if they bring him his enemies' heads. And it's an absolute rule of terror. And he uses his position of power essentially essentially, to enshrine the senatorial elite back in their kind of traditional role as arbiters of the state. So the Senate is, it literally means a kind of assembly of old men, you know, the elders, the betters, the bonnie, they call themselves, the good guys. This is how they see themselves and when Sala does this and the enemy the people that he's targeting he's targeting the populists and so that's why there are kind of so populares and I think populist would be a legitimate way to describe it the the difference between them isn't so much about policy as it would be today but about style yeah and I think and I think you
接着他悬赏人头。他在论坛上张贴清洗名单（prescription lists）。如果有人把政敌的人头带给他，就会得到赏金。这是一场绝对的恐怖统治。他利用自己的权力地位，本质上是为了巩固参议员精英阶层，让他们恢复作为国家仲裁者的传统角色。所以参议院，字面意思就是长老会议，你知道的，老者、长者、优秀的精英（boni，他们这样称呼自己，好人）。这就是他们看待自己的方式。当苏拉这样做时，他针对的敌人和平民派就是他锁定的目标。这就是为什么会有“平民派”（populares）。我认为用“民粹主义者/平民派”（populist）来形容是很贴切的。他们之间的区别与其说关乎政策（就像今天这样），不如说关乎风格。是的。而且我认为
absolutely see that that's something that over the past few decades, you know, the past few years, perhaps much more than when I wrote this, which was in the kind of first years of the 21st century, that sense of how differences in style can kind of bleed into politics and generate incredible divisions seems much clearer. And one of the populists, and he's very, very young at this point,
你绝对能看出这一点。在过去几十年里，尤其是过去几年里，这种感觉——风格上的差异如何能渗透到政治中并产生巨大的分裂——似乎比我写这本书时（那是在21世纪初的几年）要清晰得多。其中一位平民派，当时非常非常年轻，
is Julius Caesar, and he flees into exile. And for Caesar, that experience of having to hide out in barns, of being hunted across Italy, of knowing that there are people who will be paid if they can get his head. And he's, what is that? Because he's very young though, Tom. He's very, very young. Why has he been identified as a target by Sulla?
就是尤利乌斯·凯撒，他逃亡流亡。对于凯撒来说，那种不得不躲在谷仓里、在意大利各地被追捕、知道有人会因提他的人头而获得赏金的经历……托马斯，那是怎么回事？因为他当时非常年轻。为什么他被苏拉锁定为目标？
Well, he's related by marriage. So his family have married into Marius's family. So he's very much on the kind of the Marian side. He's very much on the populist side. And he identifies with that kind of side in this terrible schism. He survives it. And Caesar will express astonishment at this later in his career. Sulla lays down his powers. He retires to the Bay of Naples. He know, he's basically kind of, he's recalibrated the Republic, the functioning, the plumbing of the Republic, so that basically his guys, his class of person will be in power. And then he retires.
因为他有姻亲关系。他的家族和马略的家族结成了姻亲。所以他非常倾向于马略派这一边。他非常倾向于平民派这一边。在这个可怕的分裂中，他认同了那一派。他活了下来。凯撒在后来的职业生涯中对此表达过惊讶。苏拉卸下了权力。他退隐到那不勒斯湾。你知道的，他基本上重新校准了共和国、共和国的运作机制和内部结构，以便基本上他的人、他那一阶层的人能够掌权。然后他退休了。
But he then lays it down. So Caesar is able to come back as an enthusiast for the Republican ideal of citizenship, that anyone could have done what Sulla did. He's offended. He's appalled by it. The irony. So right the way through his career, Caesar will be renowned for his clementia his his his mercy and there's something aristocratic about that it's humiliating for a roman to be shown clementia by by another citizen but there is another way of seeing that which is that um
但他随后卸下了权力。因此凯撒得以回归，作为公民身份共和理想的热情拥护者——任何人都可以做苏拉做过的事。他被此冒犯了。他对此感到震惊。真是讽刺。因此在整个职业生涯中，凯撒以其“宽容”（clementia）——他的仁慈——而闻名。这其中有一种贵族式的作风：对于一个罗马人来说，接受另一个公民的“宽容”是令人羞辱的。但还有另一种看待方式，那就是
it's an expression of caesar's feeling that there should properly be a kind of civic commonality yeah and that to offend against that, ultimately is to offend against the deepest ideals of the Roman Republic. So he thinks that politics has limits, basically. I think so, yes. I think so. I mean, so he's a very, very, very complex figure.
这是凯撒的一种感觉的表达：应该恰当地存在一种公民共性。是的，违背这一点，最终就是违背了罗马共和国最深层的理想。所以他认为政治是有底线的，基本上是这样。我想是的，是的。我想是的。我的意思是，他是一个非常、非常、非常复杂的人物。
But I think that you could say that through his career, he's motivated by two great ideals. One is that his own genius should have free reign. And that's a crucial part of it. You know, he absolutely feels that no limits should be set on his ability to achieve great things, both for himself, but also for Rome. But he does also have an incredibly strong sense of loyalty towards those of his fellow citizens who back him. And that in due course is why he will become a great military leader and why he will win the love of his soldiers. So that sets up who Julius Caesar was and we will crack on with the story,
但我认为你可以说，在他的整个职业生涯中，他受到两个伟大利想的驱使。一是他的个人天才应该得到自由发挥。这是至关重要的一部分。你知道的，他绝对觉得不应该对他在成就伟大事业（既为了自己，也为了罗马）方面的能力施加任何限制。但对于那些支持他的同胞，他确实也具有一种极其强烈的忠诚感。假以时日，这就是他为什么会成为一位伟大的军事统帅，为什么会赢得士兵爱戴的原因。这就奠定了尤利乌斯·凯撒是谁的基调，接下来我们将继续这个故事，
Tom Holland, after a very quick break in which advertisers will promote Roman themed goods. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
托马斯·霍兰，在一段非常短暂的广告插播之后，广告商将推广罗马主题的商品。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及一剂娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history now i don't know about you but um i was delighted with the hall that father christmas brought to our household and chief among the things things that he brought was a board game for my son called Herd Mentality. And the reason I really enjoy playing that board game is because so much of my time I spend on the Internet reading a publication that pushes back against herd mentality.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。现在，我不知道你怎么想，但我对圣诞老人给我们家带来的收获感到非常高兴。他带来的主要东西之一是我儿子的一款名为“羊群心态”（Herd Mentality）的桌游。我之所以非常喜欢玩这款桌游，是因为我把很多时间都花在互联网上，阅读一份反对羊群心态的出版物。
Tom Holland, do you know what that publication is? Would it be unheard.com? U-N-H-E-R-D. U-N-H-E-R-D. Exactly. And they very much encourage independent thinking they've got an excellent article at the moment i understand by somebody called peter franklin he's got an article do you know what the title is no it's restorations always fail whether it's old labor the monarchy or
托马斯·霍兰，你知道那是什么出版物吗？难道是 unheard.com 吗？U-N-H-E-R-D。U-N-H-E-R-D。完全正确。他们非常鼓励独立思考。我了解到，目前有一篇由彼得·富兰克林（Peter Franklin）撰写的非常棒的文章。他写了一篇文章，你知道标题是什么吗？不知道。是“复辟总是失败，无论是旧工党、君主制还是
america after trump history shows that there is no going back very apt tom for a podcast about the fall of the roman republic don't you think is there is there a reference perhaps to roman republican history he says while firmly restoring the old order sulla made a mistake he allowed the son-in-law of sinner the defeated populist leader to escape with his life the name of that young man albert einstein diana spencer no gaius julius caesar the lesson here says peter franklin is simple just because you defeated one populist it doesn't mean that another more capable one isn't waiting for you down the line who's he thinking of do you reckon no idea don. Oh, goodness. I don't think so. That's a chilling thought.
特朗普之后的美国，历史表明没有回头路”。托马斯，这对于一个关于罗马共和国灭亡的播客来说非常贴切，你不觉得吗？这里面是否有什么对罗马共和国历史的暗示？他说：“在坚决恢复旧秩序的同时，苏拉犯了一个错误：他让被击败的平民派领袖西纳（Cinna）的女婿带着性命逃脱了。”那个年轻人的名字是阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦？戴安娜·斯宾塞？不，是盖乌斯·尤利乌斯·凯撒。彼得·富兰克林说，这里的教训很简单：你打败了一个平民派，并不意味着未来不会有另一个更有能力的平民派在等着你。你觉得他在想谁？完全不知道，唐。哦，天哪。我不这么认为。这是一个令人不寒而栗的想法。
Well, again, I wouldn't, yes. I think it's harsh on Caesar to compare him to Trump, but we've already discussed that. But yeah, no, it's an excellent point and an excellent illusion. Well, for excellent points and illusions, you should go to unheard.com more often. Yeah.
好吧，同样的，我不会……是的。我认为把凯撒和特朗普进行比较对凯撒太严苛了，但我们已经讨论过这一点了。不过是的，这是一个极好的观点，也是一个极好的隐喻。好吧，要想看到极好的观点和隐喻，你应该更经常地访问 unheard.com。是的。
And isn't it wonderful that 2 000 years and more after caesar's assassination he's still being mentioned in online publications yes and push back against her mentality what caesar caesar was of course you will know caesar was in debt wasn't he in his career so financial prudence mattered to him enormously yes it did so he would have been very keen on special offers and unheard you know i don't think he would So he would have been very keen on special offers. And Unheard.com. Do you know, I don't think he would. Do you? No. You're spoiling my brilliant link.
难道不觉得奇妙吗？在凯撒遇刺两千年后的今天，他依然在线上出版物中被提及。是的，而且还能对抗羊群心态。你知道的，凯撒当然负债累累，不是吗？在他的一生中，财务审慎对他的职业生涯至关重要，对吧？是的，确实如此。所以他会非常热衷于特价优惠，而 Unheard……你知道的，我不认为他会……
No, he would have rejected that offer because he would have probably spent double. He would have paid more for it. But for most people who aren't Julius Caesar. Yeah, what a fool. Dominic, you're about to say there's a splendid offer, isn't there? There is. There's a splendid offer for Rest is History listeners. So don't be like Julius Caesar.
所以他会非常热衷于特价优惠。还有 Unheard.com。你知道，我不认为他会。你觉得呢？不。你毁了我精彩的植入。
No, don't. Go to Unheard.com slash rest that's u-n-a-t-r-d you'll get your first three month subscription free because i think the moral of this podcast if it has a moral is having people like julius around isn't always good news it's very bad news yeah so save the republic take up this special offer. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, Tom, before we get back to Julius Caesar, can we just paint in a little bit more of the sort of surrounding picture? Sulla retires, and then Rome doesn't slip fully into dictatorship, does it? They basically go back to the old system. I mean i mean it's weakened but they're
不，他会拒绝那个优惠，因为他可能会花双倍的钱。他会为之支付更多。但对于大多数不是尤利乌斯·凯撒的人来说……是的，真是个傻瓜。多米尼克，你正要说这里有一个极好的优惠，对吧？没错。对于《历史的余烬》的听众来说，有一个极好的优惠。所以别像尤利乌斯·凯撒那样。
they're they carry on as though it hadn't happened and the the big new sort of the vunderkind the young meteor is pompey who's the the sort of baby-faced um ruthless butcher he's called teenage butcher you called him that didn't you or was that... No, that's it. That's the name that he's given. So he'd been one of Sulla's hitmen, basically, had he? Is that fair? Yeah. So he's a kind of a local bigwig in Eastern Italy. And he raises a private army, as does also uh big hitter called Crassus yeah and
不，别那样。前往 Unheard.com/rest，也就是 u-n-h-e-a-r-d.com/rest，你就可以免费获得前三个月的订阅，因为我认为这个播客如果有什么道德教训的话，那就是身边有尤利乌斯这样的人并不总是好消息，这是非常糟糕的消息。是的，所以拯救共和国吧，接受这个特价优惠。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。现在，托马斯，在我们回到尤利乌斯·凯撒之前，我们能再描绘一点周边的背景吗？苏拉隐退后，罗马并没有完全滑向独裁统治，对吧？他们基本上回到了旧体制。我的意思是，虽然被削弱了，但他们
Pompey and Crassus both have meteoric careers in the wake of of Sulla so they're kind of Sulla's boys basically they're Sulla's boys and uh basically you know Sulla has has weighted it so that um people who backed him are kind of in pole position to win advancement. Most of them do it in the traditional way, going up through the magistracies. Crassus does it by, he becomes incredibly wealthy. So one of his wheezes is that he employs Rome's only fire service. And he will then, you know, he'll of wait for for buildings to be on fire and then charge the uh the kind of hapless people money to put it out and he'll then buy it up and build
他们继续前行，就像什么都没发生过一样。其中崭露头角的“神童”（vunderkind）、那位年轻的流星式人物就是庞培，也就是那个娃娃脸的、冷酷的屠夫——他被称为“少年屠夫”，你是这么叫他的，对吧？还是说……不，就是这样。这就是人们给他的绰号。所以他基本上是苏拉的打手之一，对吗？这样说公平吗？是的。所以他是意大利东部的一位地方大员。他建立了一支私人军队，另一个重量级人物克拉苏（Crassus）也这么做了。
new blocks of flats everywhere that's very dare i say it's quite trumpian behavior it's very very trumpian but but crassus is a much kind of chillier more controlled more ruthless more intelligent figure right then say trump okay pompey is so he models himself on alexander the great yeah um he has the quiff of alexander the great um he he ends up sourcing what he claims is the cloak of alexander the great obviously some guy in some eastern bazaar has vlogged it to him um but the um and alexander the great is a kind of very ambivalent figure in rome because he's a king uh and he's a conqueror and he's seen as being a tyrant so pompey's identification with him isn't entirely positive and it's reflective of the fact that that there are very kind of strict age thresholds in the Republic for when you can
庞培和克拉苏在苏拉之后都经历了火箭般的职业生涯，所以他们基本上是苏拉的人。他们是苏拉的人，而且基本上（你知道的）苏拉做了权衡，使那些支持他的人处于晋升的有利地位。他们大多数人是通过传统方式、沿着官阶逐级上升的。克拉苏则是通过变得极其富有来做到这一点的。所以他的绝招之一就是雇佣罗马唯一的消防队。然后他会（你知道的）等待建筑物着火，接着向那些倒霉的人索要钱财来灭火，然后把房子买下来，到处建设
hold a magistracy. So most of the Romans absolutely adore middle age. So you become 40, you can run for consul. So it's great. I mean, you know, we become 40 and it's, oh God, I'm middle aged. I'm so depressed, midlife crisis, get a motorbike. There you go. Brilliant. Now I can run for the consulship, which is why if you look at the portrait busts of Romans from the Republican era, they all look incredibly old. Kind of crow's feet and baggy eyes and all that kind of stuff. But Pompey ignores that and he just kind of gets as many commands as he can. And he ends up through a kind of complicated process being given command of basically the whole of the east and the east is an absolute mess the romans haven't wanted to run it equally they haven't wanted to allow anyone
新的公寓楼。这非常……我敢说，这相当具有特朗普式的行为。这非常、非常特朗普化，但克拉苏是一个比特朗普更冷酷、更有控制力、更无情、也更聪明的人物，好吗？那么庞培呢？他以亚历山大大帝为自己的模范。是的，他留着亚历山大大帝式的蓬松发型。他最终设法找到了他声称是亚历山大大帝斗篷的东西——显然是某个东方集市上的家伙把它兜售给他的——但是……亚历山大大帝在罗马是一个非常矛盾的人物，因为他是一个国王，是一个征服者，被视为暴君。因此，庞培对他的认同并不完全是积极的，这反映了一个事实：共和国对于何时可以担任官职有着非常严格的年龄门槛。所以大多数罗马人极其崇拜中年。当你年满40岁时，你就可以竞选执政官。所以这太棒了。我的意思是，你知道的，当我们年满40岁时就会觉得：“天哪，我中年了，我太沮丧了，中年危机，买辆摩托车吧。”就是这样。太棒了。现在我可以竞选执政官了。这也是为什么如果你看共和时代罗马人的肖像半身胸像，他们看起来都老得不可思议。带着鱼尾纹、眼袋以及所有这些东西。但庞培无视这一点，他只是尽可能多地谋取指挥权。最终，通过一个复杂的过程，他被授予了基本上整个东部的指挥权。东部是一团绝对的乱麻，罗马人不想统治它，但同样，他们也不想让任何……
um to uh any of the kind of local kings or rulers to have any position of authority so basically it's all just collapsed into um anarchy so pompey goes over there and he conquers the whole lot. And when he comes back to Rome, he brings kings in his wake. He's stupefyingly rich. He has all the plunder of these. He has this incredible triumph where in his triumph, they carry an enormous kind of bust of him, complete with quiff, entirely modelled out of pearls. And it's kind of borne aloft so that everyone can see it
当地的国王或统治者拥有任何权威地位。所以基本上，这一切都崩溃成了无政府状态。因此庞培去了那里，征服了整个东部。当他回到罗马时，他身后带着各国的国王。他富可敌国。他拥有所有这些战利品。他举行了一场不可思议的凯旋式，在凯旋式中，人们抬着一个巨大的他的半身像，带着蓬松的发型，完全由珍珠镶嵌而成。这个雕像被高高举起，好让每个人都能看到。
and this is magnificent splendid he's the hero of the hour it redounds gloriously to the reputation of rome but it's also deeply deeply offensive to people who see themselves as his peers and one person who really detests it is crassus who has always been Pompey's great rival say Pompey and Crassus for instance between them suppressed the the rebellion of Spartacus the great slave revolt yeah actually it was Crassus who did it but Pompey turns up and nicks the glory which is kind of he's he's a glory hogger so Pompey finds to his fury and disappointment that even though he's he's by far the richest you know he's got this wealth he's got this power he's he's um conquered half the east people who he views as kind of worthless political schemers are getting together and are frustrating
这真是宏伟壮观。他是当之无愧的英雄，这为罗马的声誉增光添彩，但也深深地、深深地冒犯了那些把自己视作他同辈的人。其中一个真正痛恨这一点的人就是克拉苏，他一直以来都是庞培的死敌。比如庞培和克拉苏两人联手压制了斯巴达克斯的叛乱——伟大的奴隶起义。是的，实际上是克拉苏干的，但庞培却跑来抢功，他是一个“抢功精”。所以庞培极其愤怒和失望地发现，尽管他是最富有的（你知道的，他拥有财富，拥有权力，他征服了半个东方），但那些他眼中毫无价值的政治阴谋家却聚在一起，挫败
what he wants to do and frustrating what he wants to do. And basically what he wants to do is he wants to provide land for his veterans and he wants his settlement of the East to be ratified. And his enemies in the Senate refuse to do this. And this is classically how the Republic has functioned, is that if you are over, if you are high achieving, then your enemies will gang up and form a consortium and kind of block you out. So Pompey is in a mess. And so he looks around for allies and he comes up with two allies. One of them is astonishing.
他想做的事，挫败他想做的事。基本上，他想做的是为他的老兵提供土地，并希望他平定东部的成果得到批准。而他在元老院的敌人拒绝这样做。这正是共和国以往的运作方式：如果你太优秀、如果你成就显赫，你的敌人就会联合起来结成联盟，把你排挤出去。所以庞培陷入了困境。于是他四处寻找盟友，最终找到了两个盟友。其中一个令人震惊。
One of them is Crassus. So he's an arch enemy. He's an arch enemy. But Crassus basically decides that the pleasure of hating Pompey has to come second to his own ambition. Yeah. So Crassus always puts ambition first. So do you know what this is, Tom? What?
其中一个就是克拉苏。所以他是死敌。他是死敌。但克拉苏基本上决定，痛恨庞培的快感必须排在他的个人野心之后。是的。所以克拉苏总是把野心放在第一位。所以你知道这是什么吗，托马斯？什么？
This is 1997. It is John Redwood and Ken Clark teaming up in the Tory leadership contest. That's exactly what it is. Against William Hague. Yeah, that's exactly what it is. I know it's a very niche reference, but about two listeners will be pleased by that. No, that's exactly what it is. I know it's a very niche reference, but about two listeners will be pleased by that. No, that's exactly what it is.
这是1997年。这是约翰·雷德伍德（John Redwood）和肯·克拉克（Ken Clarke）在保守党领袖竞选中联手。完全就是这样。对抗威廉·黑格（William Hague）。是的，完全就是这样。我知道这是一个非常小众的典故，但大约会有两位听众为此感到高兴。不，完全就是这样。我知道这是一个非常小众的典故，但大约会有两位听众为此感到高兴。不，完全就是这样。
And so they basically, what Crassus and Pompey are both going to do is essentially a kind of criminal operation to force through the measures that they both want that can only be done in a criminal way. And to do that, they need a consul who will force through the measures that they both want that that can only be done in a criminal way and to do that they need a consul who will force through the measures so tame consul basically well kind of a tame consul but a consul who is willing to attract to to to put up with the opprobrium that
所以他们基本上……克拉苏和庞培要做的是进行某种犯罪性质的操作，强行推行他们都想要、但只有通过犯罪手段才能达成的措施。为了做到这一点，他们需要一个执政官来强行推行他们双方都想要、但只有通过犯罪手段才能达成的措施。为了做到这一点，他们需要一个执政官，一个顺从的执政官，基本上……嗯，算是一个顺从的执政官，但这个执政官愿意承受充当他们代理人所带来的骂名。
that acting as as their kind of agent will bring and there's an obvious person and that who is it julius caesar so julius caesar has compared to crassus and pompey had a had a much less um kind of successful career he again has gone through the hoops he's gone up the steps there's a famous story that that caesar is in in spain and he goes to a temple and sees a statue of Alexander and weeps that Alexander had conquered the world and he has done nothing he should have read my book he should have done he didn't that aspiring last paragraph yeah um so Caesar is very very ambitious he's very very able he's very very popular he spent enormous amounts of money that he doesn't have on basically making himself popular. So he's the first person to stage gladiators dressed entirely in silver armour, for instance.
这里有一个显而易见的人选，他是谁？尤利乌斯·凯撒。所以与克拉苏和庞培相比，尤利乌斯·凯撒的职业生涯要远为不成功。他同样经历了层层考验，一步步向上爬。有一个著名的故事说，凯撒在西班牙时，去了一座神庙，看到了一尊亚历山大雕像，便痛哭流涕，因为亚历山大征服了世界，而自己却一事无成。他应该读读我的书的。他本该读的。他没有读。那段令人向往的最后一段……是的……所以凯撒极其雄心勃勃，能力极强，极受欢迎。他花巨资（其实他根本没有那么多钱）来为自己博取人气。所以他是第一个举办角斗士表演的人，角斗士们穿的盔甲全都是银制的，比如说。
He's a kind of political showman. That's what he is. So to use another absolutely ridiculous modern comparison, is he sort of slightly Boris Johnson in his have I got news for you? Yes. Yes. So, again, obviously any comparison with Julius Caesar and any political figure on the current British state would be ridiculous. It is ridiculous. But he's a joke.
他是一个政治秀场操盘手。他就是这样的人。所以，用另一个绝对荒谬的现代比喻来说，他是不是有点像上过《讽刺一周》（Have I Got News for You）的鲍里斯·约翰逊？是的。是的。所以，再次声明，任何将尤利乌斯·凯撒与当今英国政坛的任何政治人物进行比较显然都是荒谬的。这太荒谬了。但他是个笑话……
Well, he's not a joke. No, he's not a joke. He's not a joke. But he's a joke. He's not. Well, he's not a joke. No, he's not a joke. He's not a joke. But he's a crowd pleaser. That's the difference. He's seen as being dangerous. So Sulla, people had gone to him and said, look, pardon Caesar. And Sulla had said there are a lot of Marius's in that young man.
好吧，他不是个笑话。不，他不是个笑话。他不是个笑话。但他是个笑话。他不是。好吧，他不是个笑话。不，他不是个笑话。他不是个笑话。但他是个能取悦大众的人。这就是区别。他被视为是危险的。所以苏拉当时有人去对他说：“看在上帝份上，赦免凯撒吧。”而苏拉曾说过：“那个年轻人身上有很多个马略。”
Okay. So people knew he was substantial. Sulla had seen that he was very, very able. And actually he describes him as, as loosely belted. So Caesar wears his toga in a fashionably loose belted way. And he's a dandy.
好吧。所以人们知道他很有分量。苏拉已经看出他能力极强。事实上，苏拉形容他“系带宽松”。所以凯撒穿托加长袍时，系带方式是一种时髦的宽松风格。他是一个花花公子。
He does spectacular kind of, he, he borrows enormous amounts of money to, to, to set, to build a villa. He then decides he doesn't like the villa. So he has the villa pulled down.
他做出了一些极为壮观的举动……他借了巨额资金来建造一座别墅。然后他发现自己不喜欢这座别墅，于是派人把别墅拆了。
And this is the kind of stunt that appalls lots of senators, to build a villa. He then decides he doesn't like the villa, so he has the villa pulled down. And this is the kind of stunt that appalls lots of senators, but equally it kind of appeals to lots of voters as well. Well, when we started our podcast, Tom, we had an episode, one of the very first episodes we did was about parallels. We were talking about Donald Trump in historical context. And you compared him to, I mean the the title of the podcast was is Trump Caesar or or isn't that wasn't it is Trump Caesar or Nixon or something and you had this thing about the Romans having this Roman politics
这是那种让许多元老院成员大惊失色的举动，借巨额资金建造一座别墅。然后他发现自己不喜欢这座别墅，于是派人把别墅拆了。这是那种让许多元老院成员大惊失色的举动，但同样，它也吸引了许多选民。当我们开启播客时，托马斯，我们有一集节目，我们做的最早的几集之一就是关于平行事件的。我们当时在历史背景下谈论唐纳德·特朗普。而你把他比作……我的意思是，那期播客的标题是“特朗普是凯撒还是尼克松之类的”，你当时提到罗马人有这种角色……罗马政治
having this role that people played where they deliberately appalled the kind of the bien pensant the great and the good yes in order to win popularity with the crowds and that's what caesar's doing from the start pretty much is it yes so i think i mean i i'm sure i mentioned it this in um in that episode but i'll do it again um i think the closest parallel to what the bonnie that's the the um the kind of classic senatorial elite the people who will loathe and detest Caesar throughout his career. If you think of John McCain's funeral, where all the presidents apart from Trump went and Democrats and Republicans were joined there in the kind of the front row to mourn this great hero. And Trump's comment on McCain was he didn't like losers. He, you know, he liked his war heroes not to be captured,
有这样一种角色，人们故意去惊世骇俗，去冒犯那些温和派（bien pensant）、有权有势的精英阶层，是的，以此来赢得民众的支持。凯撒从一开始就差不多是这么做的，对吧？是的，所以我想——我确信我在那期节目中提到过这一点，但我会再说一遍——我认为与“优秀的精英”（boni，经典的参议员精英阶层，那些在整个职业生涯中都极其厌恶凯撒的人）最接近的平行事件，如果你想想约翰·麦凯恩（John McCain）的葬礼，除了特朗普之外，所有的总统都去了，民主党人和共和党人在前排齐聚一堂，悼念这位伟大的英雄。而特朗普对麦凯恩的评价是，他不喜欢失败者，他（你知道的）喜欢他的战争英雄没有被俘虏。
which is an appalling thing to say, particularly since Trump had never served. But it was also kind of darkly funny that the people did find funny because the kind of the shock of offending traditional norms was... Caesar was never... I mean, Caesar was a a great he was incredibly able
这是一番骇人听闻的言论，特别是考虑到特朗普从未服役过。但它也带有一种黑暗的滑稽色彩，人们确实觉得好笑，因为那种冒犯传统规范的冲击力是……凯撒从未……我的意思是，凯撒是一位伟大的、能力难以置信的人，
he was will turn out to be one of the greatest generals of all time he's a man of incredible ability but he does have a talent for grabbing attention or for winning the popular vote that perhaps there's just a kind of a hint of that there he he runs for consul and he wins it by a kind of massive massive majority and of course he has a colleague a guy called bibulus um who is there to stand up for the the the interests of the bonnie the the classic elite but but caesar just elbows aside. So people follow him around and empty buckets of shit over Bibulus' head. Oh dear, poor Bibulus. And when they try and oppose Caesar's measures that he's ramming through in favour of Pompey and Crassus, they get beaten up and they get forced out of the forum.
他后来证明自己是有史以来最伟大的将军之一，他有着不可思议的能力，但他确实有一种吸引眼球或赢得大众选票的天赋，也许这里面恰好有一点那样的意味。他竞选执政官，并以压倒性的巨大优势获胜。当然，他有一个同僚，一个叫毕布鲁斯（Bibulus）的家伙，他在那里是为了代表“优秀的精英”、传统精英阶层的利益，但凯撒直接把他挤开了。人们跟着凯撒，把一桶桶大便倒在毕布鲁斯头上。哦，天哪，可怜的毕布鲁斯。当他们试图反对凯撒为了庞培和克拉苏而强行通过的措施时，他们遭到殴打，并被强行赶出了论坛。
And so people say that this is the consulship not of Caesar and Bibulus, but of Julius and Caesar. But at this point, Tom, is he very much the third man in the triumvirate? Yes, he is. When they start out. And at that point, we had a couple of questions from people about Caesar and ambition. So Joshua D. Terry, for example, or Eduard Habsburg,
所以人们说，这是凯撒和比布鲁斯的执政官时期，而不是尤利乌斯和凯撒的。但在此时，汤姆，他是三头同盟中的第三号人物吗？是的，他是。当他们刚开始时。当时，我们收到了听众关于凯撒和野心的几个问题。例如约书亚·D·泰瑞，或者爱德华·哈布斯堡，
a man who has given his surname, a little bit about imperial power and the winning and losing of it so they're asking is Caesar even at this stage does he have his eyes on the prize does he see himself as another Sulla as a man who's going to wield supreme power or is he an opportunist seizing chances as they come up and you know is it is it premeditated or not this stage um he i think well i think there are two things going on in caesar's mind i think one is as i said that um he wants to do great things yeah but he wants to do great things for the republic for rome uh and he is frankly frustrated by the little guys who were trying to block him from that.
一个连姓氏都带着帝国权力及其得失印记的人。所以他们问，凯撒在这个阶段是否已经盯准了目标？他是否将自己视为另一个苏拉——一个将掌握最高权力的人——还是一个见机行事的机会主义者？你知道，这究竟是蓄谋已久还是随机应变？在这个阶段，嗯，他……我想，在凯撒的心中主要有两件事在起作用：第一，正如我所说，他想成就伟大的事业；但他想为共和国、为罗马成就伟大的事业，而且坦白说，那些试图阻挠他的人让他感到十分沮丧。
He has a consciousness of his own genius you to put the Republic in your shadow. And Pompey is on a scale beyond everyone else. I mean, Pompey is, Pompey is criminal in his methods, but conformist in his ambitions. And so there's, I think there's actually a question here from RP. Why did Pompey never do the equivalent of crossing the rubicon when he was at the height of his powers the reason he didn't do that was because ultimately he was in his heart a conservative he'd trampled down convention to get to the top but then having got to the top what he really wanted was the approval of you know the senatorial elite.
他有着一种对自身天才的自觉，你要把共和国置于你的阴影之下。而庞培的规模超越了所有人。我的意思是，庞培的方法是犯法出格的，但他的野心却是循规蹈矩的。所以这里其实有一个来自RP的问题：为什么庞培在权力的巅峰时期，从未做过类似跨越卢比孔河的事？他之所以没有这样做，是因为他内心深处其实是个保守派。他为了登上顶峰曾践踏过传统，但一旦登上顶峰，他真正渴望的其实是（你知道的）元老院精英们的认可。
Pompey was a bit of a parvenu. He wanted to be accepted by them. Caesar didn't care about that. Caesar claimed a line of descent from Venus. He could trace his ancestry all the way back beyond the beginning of the Rome to Troy. So Caesar had no hang-ups about that. And he wanted that license because he felt that he deserved it, but also because he felt that if he was going to be a great man in the Republic, it was no longer enough just to be a consul. You had to have a record of military success behind you, which would bring you
庞培有点像个暴发户。他渴望被他们接纳。凯撒根本不在乎这些。凯撒声称自己是维纳斯的后代。他的家谱甚至可以追溯到罗马建城之前、一直到特洛伊。所以凯撒对这一点没有任何心理包袱。他想要那种授权，是因为他觉得自己当之无愧，也是因为他觉得，如果他想成为共和国里的伟人，仅仅当一个执政官已经不够了。你必须背后有军事成功的记录，这能为你带来
legions who would be devoted to you. It would bring you the wealth that you could then spend on winning yourself popularity by kind of building spectacular architectural projects in Rome or handing money out to the poor or staging entertainments. And the only way to do that is for Caesar to get a command. Now, one of the things that his enemies had done before he becomes consul is to say, every consul, when he finishes his term of office, gets a kind of a posting. And they say, well, Caesar, as his posting, he can organize stuff in Italy. So basically, it's kind of, you know know he can be the head of um the motorways agency or something like that yeah and so he's not having any of that so so he basically what
忠于你的军团。它能为你带来财富，然后你可以把这些财富花在为自己赢得声望上——比如在罗马兴建宏伟的建筑项目、向穷人发放资金或举办各种娱乐活动。而做到这一点的唯一途径，就是凯撒必须获得一个军区统帅权。现在，他的敌人在他成为执政官之前所做的事情之一，就是规定每个执政官在任期结束时，都会得到某种职位分配。他们说，嗯，凯撒作为他的职位分配，可以在意大利组织一些事务。所以基本上，这就像是……你知道的，他可以去当交通管理局局长之类的人，就是这样。所以他对这种安排根本不买账，因此他基本上……
Caesar does is he looks north where uh there are various kind of provinces um one on the the uh cis-alpine Gaul on on the Italian side of the Alps the other trans Transalpine Gaul, which is a kind of the south of what's now France. And he says, I'll have those, please. And so he gets given those, and not just for one year, but for five years. And by getting that, he's in pole position to win himself the kind of power and authority and wealth and status that only Pompey has. Okay, very good. So Caesar's career is going from strength to strength. The great kind of dramas and crises, the great showdown with Pompey, they all lie ahead of him. The stage is set, if you will. Not quite at the Rubicon, but we're getting there. And I think we should come back tomorrow to find out what happens next.
凯撒的做法是，他把目光投向了北方。那里有各种各样的省份：一个是阿尔卑斯山以南的高卢，即意大利那一侧的阿尔卑斯高卢；另一个是山北高卢（外阿尔卑斯高卢），也就是现在法国南部的一部分。他说：“请把这些交给我吧。”于是他得到了这些省份，而且不是一年，是五年。通过得到这些，他处于争夺权力和权威、财富和地位的有利位置，而这种地位只有庞培才拥有。好的，非常好。所以凯撒的事业蒸蒸日上。那些伟大的戏剧性和危机，与庞培的终极大对决，都还在前方等着他。舞台已经搭好了，如果你愿意这么说的话。离卢比孔河还有点距离，但我们正在接近它。我想我们明天应该回来看看接下来会发生什么。
Now, dear listener, if you can't wait that long, I hate to tell you, but members of the Rest Is History Club can listen to the full episode already. And if you want to sign up, you go to restishistorypod.com. And if you don't, well, you only have to wait 24 hours, because maybe not even 24 hours, because the rest of the story will be out tomorrow so thank you very much tom holland and we will see you all tomorrow thank you very much goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在，亲爱的听众朋友，如果你等不了那么久，我很遗憾地告诉你，“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员已经可以收听完整的单集了。如果你想注册，可以去restishistorypod.com。如果你不想注册，好吧，你只需要等24个小时，也许甚至不到24个小时，因为故事的剩余部分明天就会发布。非常感谢你，汤姆·霍兰，我们明天见。非常感谢，再见。感谢收听“历史其余部分”。想要获取独家播客、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问相关网站。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。